the English Rose is it delicate creature
explains Elizabeth Kimani the general
manager of Messiah flowers the plant to
bloom and grow with strength it requires
not just attention but devotion
these were need special attention
because they're headed to the United
Kingdom an English Rose is the king and
rose it has the right Carla it has a
right leg and then the Rose has to
defend nicely in the bus because the
beauty of the Rose is in the opening
Britain's Prime Minister Boris Johnson
is looking to expand the country's trade
partners ahead of its looming exit from
the European Union his predecessor
attempted all sorts of moves to expand
economic relations with former African
colonies in early October the UK signed
a partnership deal with southern African
nations to keep trading freely after
brexit but that is the only deal signed
so far with former colonies while that
special relationship in Kenya is worth a
billion dollars in trade no agreement
has been made and Johnson doesn't appear
to have made a lasting impression here
last year if you recall the foreign
secretary then Boris Boris Boris Johnson
the bicycle guy and yet the UK's
dependent on many Kenyan produce
especially tea and flowers it's during
the winter months when it's cold and
grey in the United Kingdom that Kenyan
flowers are in high demand now no one
really knows what the UK will look like
then whether there'll be a deal over
brexit or not but no matter what
exporters here say the people in the
United Kingdom will be need of their
flowers it takes ten days for the
flowers to get from Kenya to the UK
because under current EU regulations the
plants have to transit through Amsterdam
which is the --use flower hub if brick
seed comes in
then we see an opportunity where we can
get into direct trade relations in the
UK meaning the consumer is able to get
like fresher flowers because of the
shorter distribution chain and also it
means that they're going to have a
longer path life the flowers will have a
longer bus life which is also good for
the consumer but the proper facilities
and train customs officials necessary
for such a trade are not yet in place in
the UK hopes for a deal between the two
countries before brexit is rapidly
fading and yet
Kimani remains confident that with
enough care these English roses will
eventually bloom in Britain standing
stoic and fazed by uncertainty Nicholas
Hawke al-jazeera Nairobi